In Turkey, Turkish officials arrested four suspects...
...in connection to the bomb attack that hit a police vehicle,...
...killing 11 and injuring 36.
In Syria, a hospital was hit in an airstrike in Aleppo,...
...killing at least 15 and injuring dozens.
In Georgia, President Giorgi Margvelashvili arrived at the NATO headquarters...
...to talk with NATO Secretary General Jens Stoltenberg.
In Russia, Maria Sharapova has been banned from competing for two years...
...by the International Tennis Federation because of her positive doping test.
And finally, security forces recover a cache of arms and ammunition...
..in India's northern Jammu and Kashmir state during patrol operations.